turkey's covered detectives
are on the hunt going into homes
tracking down
and testing all those who might have
caught the virus
there are thousands doing this across
the country answering calls from those
who have symptoms
i hope everybody not just our country
but all people
will get rid of this virus
at least find the cure
now the search begins for all those he's
been in contact with
for the past fortnight there are teams
like this
working 24 hours a day seven days a week
trying to get in contact with
everyone who's got covered anyone who's
been in contact with
someone who's got covered or who may
have covered
and this is how they've managed to get
ahead of the curve
all of them are now isolating for two
weeks
turkey has tested nearly 5 million so
far
mobilizing its test and track teams just
after the first covert positive case in
early march
they've been going ever since using an
app to help in the hunt
and claiming incredible results but do
you think you've managed to trace
absolutely everyone that's ever
had coronavirus in our own control yes
we're hundred percent sure about this
wow that's
quite a statement yes it is a quiet
statement um i can just assure you about
this information
you know with my own team as a way to
say let's say even if i give you
as a fatty as an example which it's the
center of istanbul we have traced 100
of each covered 19k case that we have
there are 24 testing labs in istanbul
alone
and testing centers at the airport for
overseas arrivals who show symptoms
in turkey it's very much a patriotic
response to a national attack
i'm proud of all all of the
team i think all of myself
for my country for all worlds
it's my okay it's really good feelings
turkey's pumped huge amounts of money
into fighting the pandemic building two
hospitals within a record 45 days
its money its economy can ill afford
with the lira plummeting to record lows
in recent weeks you wouldn't think so by
looking at this
high spec individual rooms and the
latest high-tech equipment
their treatment is aggressive and early
they're using computer tomography on
this patient who has
mild symptoms to confirm instantly if he
has covered
if we see this a prince this
image we can easily say yes
these patients have koi 19
and white areas are koit
lesions he'll now be put straight onto
the controversial hydroxychloroquine
drug
endorsed by america's president trump as
well as the antiviral
favi per revere used more recently by
china
they expect him to leave this huge
hospital in five days
all our target is be ahead of the virus
because our all our aim is
stop the progression of the disease
for the past month turkey says it's had
more recoveries than infections
they've also been using plasma from
recovered patients to try to build
immunity one doctor described it like a
vaccine
although he admitted it doesn't work on
everyone they're throwing everything at
this disease
alex crawford sky news istanbul